Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the audience
without you. I'm a guy in a room with a microphone
talking to no one and it's sad. So that's why I
want to hear from the people. We take calls via
discord. You can find our discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. This could be interesting.
Let's go to Wasif. Well, see if I can't see. Are
you are you from Bangalore? Is that what it says
in Bangladesh?
Speaker 3: I'm from Bangla.
Speaker 1: Bangladesh. Bangladesh.
Beautiful. Well, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Wasif Thank you. It's a pleasure to
talk to you. So I have a very specific question.
I have been, you know, like I'm someone who is,
you know, pretty much intrigued and interested
in overall, you know, let's say international
politics. Right. And especially U.S.. I think it
is very interesting. So this is what I have, you
know, somewhat, you know, understood regarding the
landscape right now. I see you know, we know that,
you know, U.S. has two major political parties.
Right. But if I had to, you know, divide the
kind of people that are currently in, you know,
involved in politics, let's say mainstream,
you know, politicians who are, you know,
working for the government. Right. So I see like
there are, you know, some very broad leftist,
you know, the AOC and, you know, the Justice
Democrat types. Then you have, you know, the
completely far right wing type of people. You
know, most of them, you know, endorsed by Trump,
you're going to say Trumpist. And then you
have, you know, the typical status quo,
you know, middle of the ground, you know, in in
a lot of sense. They might be, you know, like
libertarians. And in foreign policy, they are
more more or like neo cons. Sure. And right now,
you know, like it seems we have a lot in Ukraine
and there are a lot of issues, you know, that is,
you know, being generated by what and someone who
is, you know, let's say and you are I think there
is a chance that, you know, like do you think it
is possible for the, you know, of the right wing
side, you know, more or less the extreme side,
I would say, and the, you know, leftist side to
come to an agreement and, you know, form some
kind of coalition and like the other, you know,
international countries where they, you know,
make sure that they can form a coalition to get
the neocons out of power or something like that.
Speaker 1: I think here is this, isn't it? This
is very interesting. Wasif Which is there
are, there is this new kind of anti war,
right. Which is it was really spurred by Trump
saying I'm going to Hillary will get us into wars,
but I won't. So you've got that contingent.
And then you have the people like me on the
left who have been saying the US is too involved
globally. In many cases we have no right and no
responsibility to go and quote, spread democracy.
So couldn't they come together? It's a beautiful
idea. Wasif But here's why. I don't know that it
will work. The Trumpists who claim to be against
war, they're not really against war. They're
for whatever Trump tells them they're supposed
to be for. And they will, on the one hand,
say, war is bad. We're not going to do it.
We're not going to do it. And then at the same
time say, whoa, Joe Biden isn't doing nearly
enough in Ukraine. He should be sending troops
and he should be sending drones. So they're
not genuine in their opposition to, quote, war.
They just want to be contrarians and they want
something to be able to criticize Democrats with.
Speaker 3: Hey, yeah, yeah. I think you're right
in that sense about like, this is what I want
to say. You know, I think there is a side of,
let's say, you know, the Republican fan
base right now who is, you know, somewhat,
you know, jumped on the bandwagon or, you
know, if they want to, especially, you know,
after, you know, Tucker Carlson is doing all
the stuff, you know, promoting, let's say,
Putin's favorable comments. You know, even
though, you know, from a country like mine,
you know, we have no strong ties, you know,
more or less with Russia because they were,
you know, the Soviet Union. We all of the, you
know, funding primarily who helped us in our,
you know, independence. Yes. I would say that, you
know, even in that scenario, I think, you know,
there has been, you know, you know,
like I've been feeling that, you know,
there is a significant possibility of creating
such a scenario where you have, you know,
people who are on the. But they will, you know,
at least opposed, you know, let's say, too much,
you know, getting involved in wars. Right. And
like I said, you know, I don't want to you know,
it a extend discussion further. But I think there
are some, you know, left wing people right now who
are actually, you know, getting involved it. DUCAT
Right. Yeah. People come upon them, you know,
like, let's say loony left or something like that.
Speaker 1: But no, no, I understand. I think I
get the point where if it's just a question of
whether they would really work together in a good
faith coalition or whether everybody is
really there, you know, for for their own.
Speaker 2: I think I think, you know.
Speaker 3: For a country like us where we you
know, like we have people like us, you know, we
we see, you know, us getting too much involved
in war. Right. I think they should at least try
to, you know, do this idea like, you know, we,
you know, the right says, you know, let
us, you know, get some of our, you know,
compromise and, you know, live to make some of
their compromise. And then, you know, the benefit
will be getting the neocons out. Sure. I think.
Speaker 1: Now understood. Wasif Listen,
we've never had a call from Bangladesh before.
What's going on in the background? I'm so curious.
What are the noises we hear? Where are you?
Speaker 3: Oh, my house is pretty near, you know,
somewhat main street, I guess. There is a mosque
nearby. Oh, okay. So Muslim majority country
holy month of Ramadan is going on. So, you know,
people are coming out of mosques, basically, and,
you know, the noises that are on mosque.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. Well, listen,
I appreciate the call. Thank you.
Speaker 3: Hmm. Yeah,
we'll go.
Speaker 1: All
right. There is wasif from Bangladesh.
Compelling stuff. Very, very interesting